Hola cómo estás Hola Todo bien por
supuesto entonces Quién es Víctor me
encanta Víctor él era trabajaba para mí
como una especie de practicante pero fue
un gran ayudante para mi último
espectáculo y recuerdo que Fue divertido
porque encontré la misma energía que
tenía Cuando empecé con él el ambiente
que daba y todo era un poco así Esa
energía para hacer cosas y todo y que
todavía tiene creo en esto hasta cierto
punto me identifico con él
[Música]
tiene toda la razón tiene ese entusiasmo
y todo y es a veces conciencia
inconsciencia eso es de atreverse y
hacer y es eso lo que queremos verdad
porque aquí está sienta bien lo
necesitamos
entreguémonos a la emoción de la
juventud para esta edición otoño
invierno de la semana de la moda de
París 2023 en Víctor o insanto todo es
ardor entusiasmo y pasión la colección
se titula del live with the server Or
Not la vida que merecemos o no y es un
guiño a que cada uno tiene sus
ambiciones tuve la suerte de trabajar
con
que es uno de mis súper mejores amigos
me ayudó mucho desde el principio con la
marca y fue quien hizo el estampado Así
que son pinturas como ven el vestido en
la parte posterior son solo los restos
de sus pinturas que hicieron el
estampado y que juntamos jugamos con
Perlas Y así sucesivamente Y eso es todo
así que es un poco un gran todo y un
gran nada pero es una contribución
espontánea y es como siempre nos
divertimos Es cierto que la marca está
creciendo como sobrelleva la presión
buena pregunta no es fácil no nos vamos
a mentir es un trabajo muy duro cada
seis meses tiene que salir un bebé
grande es mucha logística Pero hay
tantas cosas y necesitamos tanta gente
que no nos damos cuenta pero es un
equipo de jóvenes muy motivados
apasionados que me ayudan a diario a
poder realizar nuestros sueños y mis
sueños en este caso estoy muy agradecido
con ellos
es un tesoro es un referente para el
mundo de la moda
en la extravagancia y el talento creo
para ser capaz de difuminar las
fronteras y hacer avanzar este hermoso
mundo
y lo sigo desde el principio
creo que necesitamos gente como él en
todos los círculos artísticos para
mantener el color para mantener el
brillo
y al mismo tiempo para hacer que las
cosas
la segunda joya en la categoría de joven
a la vanguardia es Vincent preciat para
presentar su colección eligió un lugar
perfectamente adecuado para transmitir
su mensaje una mansión privada en pígale
donde George pisette compuso su famosa
ópera Carmen y que se convirtió en un
prostíbulo fue una inspiración sobre
todo para liberar la palabra de las
mujeres que están demasiado encerradas
en una sociedad demasiado complicada y
realmente encuentro el lugar bastante
inspirador con su historia y el hecho de
que estamos tanto en las redes sociales
tanto siempre rodeados de tantas
personas que somos juzgados todo el
tiempo al final la red social predica
que somos libres Pero al final no lo
somos es la prisión más grande y
luminosa que existe Bueno hablemos ahora
del chifón porque esta es una colección
real con ropa real que se va a usar
exactamente después elegimos vestir
extravagante porque realmente quería ser
un homenaje a Vivian que y que me ha
inspirado enormemente en mi vida después
trabajamos mucho en todo el vestuario en
realidad muy parisino y muy burguesa de
los 16avos que tenemos en la cabeza me
inspiré mucho en la película bella de
día ves los trajecitos el acabardina que
pusimos en vinilo que también las puedes
encontrar en algodón ese tipo de cosas
Perdón Ah Ajá estás bien ya ves que
hicimos este tipo de cosas y después es
un lock muy burgués pero lo
reconvertimos Ah Y también trabajamos el
leopardo con mucha transparencia para
darle un toque sexy No es una colección
vegana en absoluto sí todas las pieles
son veganas esto debería haber quedado
Claro sí todas las pieles son veganas
absolutamente e incluso se puede ver el
terciopelo allí que se puede ver aquí es
terciopelo parece un potro se podría
pensar que ese realmente un animal pero
no lo es así que al final somos bastante
veganos
Alice pellán eligió un instituto muy
chic del distrito séptimo de París para
proclamar alto y claro su tema nadie
está obligado a ser obligado
exactamente y es un pequeño giro es algo
que se hace realmente al detalle pero en
realidad eso es todo creo que lo más
importante es poder sentirse bien ya
está y la mujer se siente guapa y sexy
sin sentirse desnuda ni exorbitante
[Música]
así sin avergonzarnos expresar nuestra
sensualidad expresarnos a través de
nuestro cuerpo poner por delante lo que
queremos sobre todo poner por delante
Eso es todo y al mismo tiempo creo que
no es una feminidad digamos a la antigua
vista y vuelta a ver porque como lo hizo
Alice bello al principio Vi que había
recuperado retales de encajes viejos así
para desestructurarlos y hacer nuevas
formas y así Hay nuevas estructuras es
bastante pero manteniendo esta línea de
encaje que tenemos en nuestras
referencias de nuestras madres quizá un
pensamiento entretejido de nostalgia o
no mirar al pasado con nuestros
compañeros para encontrar algo con lo
que construir el futuro Ese es nuestro
presente
[Música]